this is jockle podcast number 214 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening dear George at
0:00 700 this morning the BBC announced
that the German radio had just come out
with an announcement of the landing of
Allied paratroops and of large numbers
of assault craft near the shore so that
is it
this group of unconquerable heroes whom
I command are not in yet but we will be
soon I wish I was there now as it is a
lovely sunny day for a battle and I am
fed up with just sitting i have no
immediate idea of being killed but one
can never tell and none of us can live
forever so if i should go don't worry
but set yourself to do better than i
have all men are timid on entering any
fight whether it is the first fight or
the last fight all of us are timid
cowards are those who let their timidity
get the better of their manhood you will
never do that because of your bloodlines
on both sides I think I've told you the
story of marshal terrain who fought
under louis xiv on the morning of one of
his last battles he had been fighting
for 40 years he was mounting his horse
when a young aide-de-camp who had just
come from the court and had never missed
a meal or heard a hostile shot said mr.
terrain it amazes me that a man of your
supposed courage should permit his knees
to tremble as he walks out to melt
terrain replied my lord Duke I admit
that my knees do Trumbull but should
they know where I shall this day take
them they would shake even more that is
it your knees may shake but they will
always take you toward the enemy well so
much for that there are apparently two
types of successful soldiers
those who get on by being unobtrusive
and those who get on by being obtrusive
I am of the latter type and seemed to be
rare and unpopular but it is my method
one has to choose a system and stick to
it
people who are not themselves are nobody
to be a successful soldier you must know
history read it objectively dates and
even the minut details of tactics are
useless what you must know is how man
reacts weapons change but man who uses
them changes not at all
to win battles you do not beat weapons
you beat the soul of man of the enemy to
do that you have to destroy his weapons
but that is only incidental you must
read biography and especially
autobiography if you do that it will you
will find that war is simple decide what
will hurt the enemy most within the
limits of your capabilities to harm him
and then do it take calculated risks
that is quite different from being rash
my personal belief is that if you have a
50% chance take it because of the
superior fighting qualities of American
soldiers lead me led by me will surely
give you the extra 1% necessary in
Sicily I decided as a result of my
information observations and a sixth
sense
that I have that the enemy did not have
another large-scale attack in his system
I bet my shirt on that and I was right
you cannot make war safely but no dead
general has ever been criticized so you
have that way out always I am sure that
if every leader who goes into battle
will promise himself that he will either
come out a conqueror or a corpse he is
sure to win
there is no doubt of that defeat is not
due to losses but to the destruction of
the soul of the leaders the most vital
quality a soldier can possess is
self-confidence utter complete and
bumptious you can have doubts about your
good looks about your intelligence about
your self-control but to win in war you
must have no doubts about your ability
as a soldier what success I have had
results from the fact that I have always
been certain that my military reactions
were correct many people do not agree
with me they are wrong the unerring jury
of history written long after both of us
are dead will prove me correct note that
I speak of military reactions no one is
born with them any more than anyone is
born with muscles you can be born with
the soul capable of correct military
reactions or the body capable of having
big muscles but both qualities must be
developed by hardwork the intensity of
your desire to acquire any special
ability depends on character on ambition
I think that your decision to study this
summer instead of enjoying yourself
shows that you have character and
ambition and they are wonderful
possessions soldiers all men in fact are
natural hero worshipers officers with a
flair for command realize this and
emphasize in their conduct dress and
deportment the qualities they seek to
produce in their men when I was a second
lieutenant
I had a captain who was very sloppy and
usually lame he got after his men for
just those faults he was a failure the
troops I have commanded have always been
well dressed been smart salute errs been
prompt and bold an action
because I have personally set the
example in these qualities the influence
one man can have on thousands is a
never-ending source of wonder to me you
are always on parade officers who
through laziness or a foolish desire to
be popular failed to enforce discipline
and the proper wearing of uniforms and
equipment not in the presence of the
enemy will also fail in battle and if
they fail in battle they are potential
murderers there is no such thing as a
good field soldier you are either a good
soldier or a bad soldier well this has
been quite a sermon but don't get the
idea that it is my swan song because it
is not I have not finished my job yet
signed your affectionate father
and that right there if you haven't
guessed is a letter from General George
s Patton to his son that George as d-day
unfolded and as you can see from the
letter and also if you know anything
about Patton at all he was well known
not only for his skill in battle and as
a tactician and as a leader but also
well known for his ego let me read this
part again the most vital quality a
soldier can possess his self-confidence
utter complete and bumptious and what
bumptious means is is proud to in to a
degree where it's irritating so it means
what it sounds like right did he say and
that's how you need to be he continues
on you can have doubts about your good
looks about your intelligence about your
self-control but to win in a war you
must have no doubts about your ability
as a soldier what success I have had
results from the fact that I have always
been certain that my military reactions
were correct many people do not agree
with me they are wrong now that's
obviously very contrary to what I think
which is the most important
characteristic for a leader to have is
humility so we're actually saying the
exact opposite things here I mean to
straight up the opposite things he's
saying the most important thing is
self-confidence but he doesn't just say
got self-confidence he says utter and
complete and bumptious that's what he
says that's not that's not humility so
where does this wash out we have to
remember that the Patton's career was
not unblemished and and this is the
thing that I'm gonna keep kind of tying
this back to a lot of the things that I
think you remember when we did Chairman
Mao mm-hmm and we talked about Chairman
Mao and his methodology for winning in
guerrilla war and everything that he
said well
like aligned with what I say and and
what are the key components of that and
maybe not everything but a lot of what
he was saying and I'd have to review it
again but a lot of what are you saying
but one thing that he absolutely said
Chairman Mao father of Communists China
said all throughout that you know the
leaders in the field need to make
decisions they need to step up they need
to lead at what he's talking about his
decentralized command and what puzzles
me about that is because he recognized
that you needed to have decentralized
command for a military victory right to
win but then he never transposed that
idea of decentralized command into his
government and we actually do know that
centralized government doesn't work any
better than centralized a military
command than centralized business
leadership it doesn't work so he never
made that connection apparently and
sometimes when I read about Patton if
you know about Patton and you know about
his career and you know what happened to
him sometimes you you it hurts a little
bit to know that this guy who was such a
great Patriot who was such a great
tactician that if he could have applied
some of his principles of leadership on
the battlefield if he could have applied
those to his interactions with other
people
he might have ended up in a much better
position and we'll get into some of that
some of them some of the things that he
did one there was an attack on a place
called a fort jury aunt in the fall of
1944 and I got this little I wanted to
kind of summarize it and there's a thing
called the warfare history Network that
summarized it very well it's that the
entire operation gradually said settled
into a stalemate with the Americans
Americans unable to achieve any further
gains and the men hanging on desperately
to what had been one in the hard
fighting food water and ammunition were
running out and the men holding
positions underground were exposed to
the dust and fumes of the tunnels by
October 9th Patton's attitude about the
attack had changed completely
he said the show is going sour we will
have to pull out it had quickly become a
no-win situation for the Americans
because both daylight and nocturnal
assaults had failed daytime attacks were
vulnerable to the deadly fire that
rained down on Fort grant from the
adjacent forts at night assaults were
quickly quickly broken up and driven
into confusion when the German squads
emerged from their underground tunnels
the Third Army suffered 64 men killed
547 wounded 187 missing assumed captured
so and not achieving the objective so
that's not good right
so the idea to think that everything I
think of is correct and there you go
even Patton guess what he had to do he
had to go okay this isn't working he
might not like to admit that but yes
this isn't working too well M let's just
not do this another thing he did he
orchestrated a raid on a powa amp called
old frog 13b it was in Poland and
there's I'm not gonna go into the
details now but he actually thought that
perhaps his son-in-law was a prisoner
there and so he organized this this raid
and a guy named Abraham Baum conducted
the raid 300 men went on the mission of
which 32 were confirmed killed in action
and another 200 over 200 were missing or
taken prisoner and only 35 of the 300
made it back to friendly lines so that
is not good and then on top of that
here's here's what I look at and I say
if he would have had more humility and
and once again I gotta say this right
because I talk about humility all the
time there's a reason that I talk about
humility talk time okay in the dichotomy
of leadership can you be too humble
echo Charles can you be too humble yes
yes you can can you have too much
confidence yes that becomes arrogant
it's an ego that's bad the reason that I
talk about humility so much is because
it is the of the two leanings that
people can make in the dichotomy most of
us
most of the time it's they're too
confident that's most of the time right
because if you have someone that's
moving into a leadership position they
have to have some confidence to get
there so therefore a person in a
leadership position is going to lean
towards having confidence which is gonna
lean them towards if they're gonna be
either not confident enough or too
confident they're gonna lean towards too
much confidence right because the person
that lacks confident well they're not in
the leadership position they didn't work
they didn't maneuver to get them they
didn't believe in themselves they don't
really get there are there times where
you have to talk to a leader about hey
you need more confidence you need to be
less humble absolutely there are times
but Patton clearly was an example of he
leaned towards too much ego too much
confidence so what I'm saying is and and
that was part of his power too right you
get around someone that's super
confident about things and they're like
oh no we're gonna make this happen if
you go yes we are I'm following this guy
so confidence in ego is a positive thing
it absolutely is too much of it and you
can get yourself in trouble let's look
at what happened at towards the end of
the war Patton got relieved of command
they moved him out of commanding combat
troops and they moved him into a
position which was a it was like a
what's that word it was like a
figurehead position okay cool they put
him in his fate he was he may put him in
charge of the 15th the army which sounds
really cool but they were actually just
responsible for capturing the history of
what was happening so we're talking low
impact job no and by the way no command
in the Pacific because they were still
fighting and he wanted to go to the
Pacific he didn't go didn't take over
any major troops didn't even go didn't
even go to the Pacific Theater not even
in charge of like the occupation army in
Germany not even in charge of that so
think about that here's this guy and
because of his tactical prowess he did
great on the battlefield but as soon as
they could they shifted him over and put
him out to pasture why is that because
it
so that's what bums me out is because if
he would have just had some humility to
think how am I gonna play this game a
little bit better you know how am I
gonna interact with my superiors with my
superior officers how am I gonna
interact with them he probably would
have if he absolutely I should probably
what he absolutely could have ended up
being the supreme Allied commander for
sure but he didn't so that being said of
course there's all kinds of things we
can learn from Patton and who knows
maybe he was writing this maybe his son
wasn't a very confident person maybe
he's trying to bolster his son up in
this particular letter but there's a lot
of things that he wrote and I mean
there's a lot and it's awesome to read
but last time we covered letter of
instruction one and two to his troops
this is again going back towards the
towards prior to detai d-day and we
might as well just jump in the letter of
instruction number three now this one
was was very very tactical and by that I
mean very I should say you shouldn't
even say tactical because tactics is
good very specific talking about you
know types of armor and what to do in
very specific situations so I'm gonna
take a little bit less from this letter
but there's a bunch of things in here
that are relevant or powerful and things
that anybody that's in a leadership
situation can utilize so so this one's a
little bit I'm jumping around a bit skip
I shouldn't say I'm jumping around but
I'm skipping more stuff in this letter
but you can find these online if you
want to so one of the things he says to
begin with haste and speed are not
synonymous by this I mean that hasty
attacks do not produce speedy successes
or speedy advances because hasty attacks
are not coordinated attacks haste makes
waste
so rushing to get something done not
effective haste that's what he means by
haste which is weird because I think
when I think of the word haste and I
don't want to dive into like the
etymology of the word haste
but I think it has a little bit of a now
nowadays I think it has a little bit of
a positive connotation right hey we need
to make haste we need to move quick
like it's a good thing but I think even
just this short time ago it's more
aligned with the idea of haste makes
waste right like it if it's more like
rushing because rushing doesn't have a
positive connotation right you say hey
you need to rush like no one says that
no one says hey rush with your homework
to your kid you don't say rush no you
say hurry yeah you need to say move
faster but you don't say you don't say
rush because that means you're gonna
miss something yeah almost like rush
means hurry with the the the note that
it's like in a bet in a negative way or
in it like yeah and so I think this at
this time period haste had that yeah
connotation as well so he's saying haste
makes waste
continuing in an armored division as an
infantry division attacks must be
coordinated and the infantry and the
tanks and the guns must work as a unit
success depends upon the coordinated use
of guns and the tanks so what does that
mean covered move that's what it means
work together as a team all your
different elements in your company in
your team and your business need to work
together wouldn't that seem obvious
mm-hmm wouldn't it seem obvious yeah
it's not obvious yeah well it's it's
obvious it's hard to do people don't do
it like they should yeah one of the many
things that seem obvious a head or when
you're not involved in it but there are
insights you know that's why in
leadership strategy and tactics when I
was talking about what to do as a new
leader and I say like read this before
you go into a meeting read this when you
go to bed at night
because because you can't just read and
go cool there's the okay I read through
now I'm good no you need to embed it
into your brain read what the laws of
combat know the section on page 158 of
leadership strategy practice and the
reason that I know that is because
people are people said oh yeah I just
answer I gotta go to page 158 Alicia
traveling tactics yeah but you can't
just read it one time you have okay no
you need to embed those things into your
brain yeah it's not kind of like this
right how long does it take to embed in
the brain that
oh we need to work together a little bit
more cover and move here when tanks are
advancing they must use their guns for
what is known as requirement
reconnaissance by fire that is they must
shoot at any terrestrial object behind
which an anti-tank gun might be
concealed and take these targets under
fire to range greater than the range at
which an anti-tank gun is effective in
other words at a range of greater than
2,000 yards actually that's not even
really covered it's kind of a little bit
of cover move but it's that's being
proactive right hey there could be an
anti-tank gun over there the anti-tank
gun is has a range of whatever a
thousand meters at 2,000 meters I'm
hitting those targets soon I'll somebody
hit me up on it on Twitter and said
there was there's a name for that type
of shooting I can't remember what it is
but it's shooting where you think the
enemy might be in tank versus tank duels
the first round should be armor-piercing
if this fails the second round must be
white phosphorus and short so as to give
our tank a chance to maneuver because by
keeping its gun laid on with smoke it
has a better chance of getting in the
second telling shot then has the enemy
who when he emerges from the smoke does
not know the location of our vehicle
armored infantry should make a violent
attack using all its men and weapons so
that that's a cool you fire your first
shot cool the second shot you got to be
you got to put some smoke out so they
can't see what you're doing you should
have hit him on the first shot if you
don't you're good because you putting
some smoke where you still know where he
is but he has to look through this giant
smoke and so when he when the smoke
clears he doesn't know where you are and
you're getting another round on him hmm
we used to set up our magazines with
something called a party mix so do you
have different types of rounds for your
weapon and so guys would put like
armor-piercing rounds like the first
couple rounds armor-piercing rounds the
second couple I they never do they don't
think is it like the second one would be
like a a more of a anti-personnel type
round that
and this is against the Geneva
Convention it's not it's not called an
expanding round because it doesn't
expand but there's around that we have
that tumble when they hit so be some of
those than some tracers at the bottom
like all kinds of think mark you could
just guy set up a little party mix yeah
we do that with shotgun shells
oh we do do we we do here look at this
guy tactical echo well you know that
makes sense or you understand that I
understand what you're talking about
tactical echo coming in hot that's what
we do the shotgun shells
what party mix do you use my friend
educate buckshot birdshot slug you know
like you'll have one after the other you
know so they're like different you can
see how they feel or whatever yeah what
so what do you have in your home like
double okay okay yeah for the shotgun
yeah yes mm that's where your that's
where you're going with you that's what
we're going with
okay both though and to throw or to go
the whole magazine is filled with those
well they're not that's what I have but
yeah that's what I would yes I don't
know like oh the magazine deep I've got
a slug no no okay I think it's just for
fun when you do the party mix yeah or in
my experience you know my party mix is
not for friend active for fun echo
Charles nice reason for I have to think
through there's a bunch of different
reasons why you could set things up a
different way right yes I would think so
yeah you could understand this is a
welcome to the podcast
this guy got a gun and now it's all go
Jack tell let me know I'm stating buyer
tell Patton what's up Oh Chuck I
probably just shut down you ever say
anything I know gravel rear channel bond
with you and in Patton but
we're one right it is more important to
get it is more important to get the
information back fast than to get it
back secretly therefore use clear with a
limited code for name only this is
interesting so you have encrypted radios
you have codes that you can use and what
he's saying is like listen and and
sometimes especially now especially in
the past that would make transmitting
information a lot harder it takes the
power away from the signal sometimes it
just takes time to encrypt the message
and what he's saying is like listen it's
more important that we get the
information back there than it is that
we keep it all secret it's just an
interesting point to me because it shows
the importance of fast communication of
letting people know what's happening you
this is obviously something you have to
be careful of but it's an interesting
point just the fact that you have to
keep information flowing as quickly as
possible and at this time keeping it
moving fast would trump keeping it
secure mm-hmm in tactical situations
because obviously there's strategic
situations I mean we broke the German
Enigma code we broke the Japanese code
and that was massively important for us
to win the wars so continuing whenever
German anti-tank guns have gotten our
tanks it has almost always been our own
fault
in spite of years of instruction tanks
will go up obvious tank lanes such as
cart tracks open river bottoms small
roads or paths or along hedges all of
which any intelligent anti-tank gunner
will have arranged to cover isn't that
brilliant like when you're looking at
the terrain you can go on oh look at
this path if we go down that path guess
what the German Gunners are expecting to
go down that path and they're gonna be
waiting for you it's also an interesting
idea of ownership when we lose a tank
it's almost always our fault hmm
next the German anti-tank gunner is a
good shot we are better shots he is
unprotected
we are behind inches of steel if we use
our heads and our American ingenuity and
initiative we have nothing to fear from
the German anti-tank guns
you know what's crazy I just just hit me
as I'm reading this mat he's saying
these things specifically cuz guys were
scared of these German anti-tank guns
and I'm just thinking about it from a
tankers perspective when you're in a
tank you're all claustrophobic you're
locked in this thing and it's this weird
it's as weird
it's this weird dichotomy because in one
sense you feel really protected and in
another sense you feel completely
vulnerable you feel protected cuz like
all these little bullets aren't gonna
hurt you you know some Minds aren't
gonna hurt you
but then at the same time you know one
big hit and there's nothing you can do
about it you're gonna die and so that's
an interesting thing he's addressing
that that fought that can go through
someone's head is like okay yeah I feel
protected but also one hit and I'm dead
and the way that the way that when
aren't when you when your armor gets
pierced by an anti-tank gun like the the
picture being in a tank and there's just
hot hot metals spraying around and
they're gonna kill you like it's an
awful thing to picture is it heart like
okay when you're in the tank said it's
kind of claustrophobic is it it's like
hard to get in and out of that's like it
takes a little while yeah especially if
they get hit with a mine and you know
you these big giant steel doors imagine
how hard it is when that thing gets bent
a little bit oh yeah
you're not getting out oh man you're
gonna panic in there well I'm gonna
panic in there yeah yeah or even like if
you that's a nightmare and not that this
would happen all the time or whatever I
don't know but like if it just tips over
or something you got to get out of here
in the you're like kind of stuck yeah
you know it's just horrible yeah but at
the same time it's like just it is
protected like that's what you're
dealing with here yeah that's what he's
talking about here and it's the same
thing you know with these big IEDs that
the enemy makes what do you think hey
I'm protected I'm in a tank but one of
those big giant IEDs can could do some
damage
next armored battles against infantry
and anti tanks are short and violent
they take great strength of mind and
both physical and moral core encouraged
because of this violence and the speed
with which they are terminated when once
launched tanks must closed at their best
speed just the same as infantry and also
just the same as infantry they must fire
while closing next every effort must be
made to attack the flank or preferably
the rear of the enemy in executing such
an attack we must use all means at our
command to prevent the enemy from
stopping these turning movements so this
is exactly what I was talking about
think about this every effort must be
made to attack the flank or preferably
the rear of the enemy so that's
brilliant
I talk about this all the time you don't
want to attack your enemy head-on you
want to attack them from the flank right
clearly he understood that however you
can look at his history and he would
attack he would attack his superiors his
people around you know the PP r zh'
you would attack him instead of
developing a relationship instead of
coming from the flank and it ended up
putting him in his position where he
didn't get the final command that he
wanted to get so yes my my goal is to
think about Patton from a tactical
perspective and then take it one step
further and apply his his battlefield
tactics to leadership and I wish he
would have done that
here he says to summarize and here's
where he kind of rap I skipped a bunch
of stuff but to summarize we must take
great and calculated risks in the use of
armor but we must not dive off the deep
end without first determining whether
the swimming pool is full of water
that's the dichotomy of leadership yes
you have to take risk but no you don't
just jump in this is a good one
you must never halt because some other
unit is stuck if you push on you will
release the pressure on the adjacent
unit and it will accompany you that is
really smart right you want to use
someone next to you gets bogged down and
you stop to help them and now you're
gonna get bombed yeah so don't do that
this is this was Dean lat
going into Tarawa and the order was for
all the Marines if someone gets hit keep
going that's what we need to do and
thankfully for Dean lad his men wouldn't
didn't obey that order but if everyone
didn't obey that order on that day they
never would have made it to the beach
mm-hmm
so it's that's not just a one on one
that's the same with units as well next
troops are never defeated by casualties
but by a lack of resolution of guts
battles are won by a few brave men who
refused to fear and push on it should be
our ambition our ambition to be members
of this heroic group so you're never
gonna lose a battle because the
casualties you're gonna lose because of
lack of resolution of guts more
casualties occur among those who hold or
go to the rear than among those who
advance and advance firing that's
default aggressive or nah gonna run back
we're not gonna stop we're gonna be
default aggressive and keep maneuvering
finally all of us must have a desperate
desire and determination to close with
the enemy and to destroy him
desperate desire I kind of just breezed
through those words but think about what
those words mean a desperate desire and
determination to close with the enemy
and just destroy him boom he's got a
little section here called common
tactical faults it is nearly always a
mistake to occupy obvious cover this is
particularly true in sparsely wooded
country because the woods are clearly
marked on maps and in the enemy
possession and they will almost
invariably be subject of concentration
this we used to see this when I was
running training we'd put guys out on
reconnaissance and they're doing a
reconnaissance of some target and if
there was you look up at like a hillside
and there's like one little group of
shrubs you can take your your opposing
force guys go hey go check out those
shrubs and there's like a 60% chance
there's the little seal squad or a
little seal fire team sitting in there
with a camera mm-hmm and you just walk
up there and gee big surprise there was
three outcroppings of brush and you're
in one of them what a surprise so that's
what he's saying here
don't take the obvious cover when the
fire starts bayonets should be fixed
they encourage our soldiers and
discourage the enemy when a platoon or
any other commander moves to the front
to reconnoiter during a firefight
he must not move to the rear to
disseminate information he is acquired
but rather the unit must come up to him
the sight of officers moving to the rear
has a disturbing effect on the troops
and serves no useful purpose that's a
brilliant little thing to think about
hey I'm gonna go out I'm gonna go up and
find out what's going on in 40 minutes
send someone to this location and I'll
tell you what's going on mmm or send
this squad up after me and I'll tell you
what's going on
next and again of skipping a bunch but
these are the key points there is a
ridiculous and widespread fear among all
our troops that they will run out of
ammunition particularly small arms
ammunition if my in my experience this
has never happened
troops should remember that if they save
ammunition which they could have
effectively expended against the enemy
for some unforeseen contingency they
will also save the lives of a number of
enemy who will participate in the
contingency so he's saying get some I
can tell you that uh guys in Ramadi ran
out of ammunition even though he may not
have experienced it happened it happens
the that little story I've told before
about Mikey Mansour making this video
yeah and me showing up and everyone say
to go go watch Mikey's video and I'm
like cool I go watch Mikey's video and
it's him going away and he shows it to
me and of course I'm mr. serious you
know and I say Mikey there's a firefight
going on what are you doing taking a
video and you think I was guess guess
makes a video but yes you can't run out
an enemy out of fire munitions so maybe
not a hundred percent agree with that on
that one the necessity for using all
weapons to their maximum fire capacity
during our attacks cannot be too
strongly impressed on the soldiers any
gun that is not firing is not doing its
job in the assault we're marching fire
is used by the infantry every gun
machine gun and mortar must fire so yeah
I mean that's what he's talking about I
think even even to the previous point
he's talking about these assaults where
you have a massive logistics train right
behind you so you're not you should
really shouldn't run out of ammunition
unlike you know what we were doing where
you might not have logistics train right
there behind you you might have you
might be kind of stuck out in the city
somewhere for a little while mm-hmm so
yeah get some with the guns
at the close of a fight it is very
desirable that our own dead be removed
from view as rapidly as possible after
this has been accomplished the enemy
dead should be removed with the same
reverence we Accord our own and given a
proper burial next there is a
regrettable tendency on the part of
company officers and noncommissioned
officers to accompany the firing line as
if they were members on of a
well-trained chorus simply keeping
position this attitude of mind and the
actions resulting from it is impossible
in battle officers and noncommissioned
officers are there for the purpose of
seeing that all what the weapons of
their respective little commands are
functioning they cannot see this by
simply accompanying accompanying the
movement they must direct it this is the
thing about this that that I think of
and I've talked about this before with
stoner Seth stone who is the Delta
platoon commander in task unit bruiser
and him wanted him staying exactly where
he was supposed to stay according to the
standard operating procedures while
executing maneuvers on the battlefield
there's like a there's like a
predetermined place where everyone's
supposed to be and I was watching him
but he'd be in like the perfect
predetermined place but the
predetermined place that you're in
doesn't always allow you to see what you
need to see as the leader so you
actually just because that's the
standard operating procedure there are
deviations that you can make and that
you need to make as the leader to make
sure that you can see what's going on
you can see what the next maneuvers
supposed to be and that's sort of what
he's talking about here but what he's
saying is you aren't just going along
with the movement you got to make it
happen it's the same thing I'll say in
stone early hey once the call gets made
it's not just they're gonna execute it
you got it direct it you've got to get a
control of it and make it go to the
right place
and then he says this key point in this
letter as in those preceding it I am not
laying down inflexible rules
I am simply giving you my ideas so even
this guy who thinks that he's so smart
and thinks that all of his military
intuitions are 100% correct and will be
proven out in history to be the right
call even this guy is saying listen I'm
not laying down like things that you can
adapt from I'm just giving you what my
ADIZ are and then he says I must and do
trust your military experience courage
and loyalty to make these ideas tangible
there are many ways of fighting all of
which are good if they are successful so
even the great what's that word bum
Jewess yes General Patton is saying look
I know I told you like I'm right all the
time but do what you got to do no these
aren't these aren't inflexible rules do
what you got to do then he wraps this
one up we are now entering the final
stage of a Great War of a great victory
this victory can be obtained by the
maximum use of all weapons both physical
and spiritual it is the duty of all
commanders to see that their men are
fully aware of the many vile deeds
perpetrated upon civilian civilization
by the Germans and that they attack with
the utmost determined determination
ferocity and hate I am sure that every
man will do his duty and I'm therefore
sure that victory is simply a question
of when we find the enemy so it's
interesting that he's actually telling
them you need to attack with hate it's a
different level this is total war
this isn't like oh well you know attack
with some dislike we're going to attack
with hate and that's how he wraps up
that was a letter of instruction number
three this is letter of instruction
number four now they're starting to make
some adjustments he says the acute
supply situation confronting us has
caused the supreme commander to direct
that until further orders the Third Army
with its supporting troops and those
elements of the ninth army placed in the
line will assume the defensive what you
know he doesn't really like very much
being on defensive it is evident that
the successful accomplishment of this
mission will require particular
concentration upon two points first this
change in attitude on our part must be
completely concealed from the enemy who
should he learn of it would certainly
move troops to our front and oppose
other allied armies so he's saying look
we can't let them know that we're going
on the defensive because then they'll
just you know back off and go attack
somewhere else and he says second we
must be in possession of a suitable line
of departure so that we can move rapidly
when the supreme commander directs us to
resume the offensive and then he says in
order to carry out the requirements of
paragraph 2a which is the one I just
read we will not dig in wire or mine but
we will utilize a thin outpost zone
backed at suitable places by our
powerful mobile reserves we will further
ensure that all possible avenues of tank
attack are registered in all of our
batteries whose guns can bear
counter-attacks by our mobile reserves
should be planned and executed to secure
a double envelopment of the hostile
effort with the purpose of not only
defeating it but destroying it so so
that's pretty what he's saying is it's
kind of the same strategy that the
Russians take when people attack Russia
which is look we got a little line of
defense when we get attacked we're gonna
back in a little bit back off a little
bit and then you know back off a little
bit more and then they attack you and
back off a little bit more and then when
the time is right we'll we'll surround
them and destroy them all that's what
he's saying but he's saying look that's
why we left that's why we don't have to
dig in we're putting a thin line of
defense out there and then when we get
attacked we'll just back up we got here
we got strong defense further back but
we're just gonna back up we're gonna
lower the enemy in and then we're gonna
envelop them
very
simple the other thing that's good about
it is when you're not dug in as soon as
you get the order to attack boom we're
going on the attack
because we're not dug in mm-hmm which is
again something I talked about
leadership strategy and tactics which I
wish the patent would have read my
chapter sorry
speaking of ego mm-hmm
there you go revealed I wish Patton read
my chapter about don't dig in because
how often did Patton think hey this is
how we should do something and when he
didn't when he got told another way
instead of saying okay I understand what
K will go for it it was resistance it
was okay well we'll do it but he didn't
like it and he let that be known which
again look I did it oh I'm not gonna
just do what somebody tells me to do if
I don't agree with it no I'm not saying
that and there's time we've doesn't make
any sense whatsoever cool you know then
maybe there's a time we draw a line in
the sand but these were big giant
operations where it's like okay we do it
like this we'll do it like that no we
should do it my way
mm-hmm and so much resistance and you're
gonna end up doing it anyways by the way
that he just didn't develop the kind of
relationships that he needed and he
didn't gain the kind of trust that he
needed up the chain of command where
they put him in just senior positions
where he could have had even more impact
don't dig in don't dig it around your
ideas don't dig in even on the defense
sometimes which I hesitate to say cuz
let me let me tell you let me just make
this note if you're in a truly defensive
position dig in because the enemy is
gonna attack you and you don't want to
be you want to have a place that you can
get good cover from the enemy attack so
I'm not saying never dig in sure I'm
saying most of the time don't take it
alright now this next section is from
something that Patton wrote I wanna say
you wrote it in 1926 something like that
but way before World War 2 what it was
after he got done with
World War 1 and once again not reading
reading the whole thing but I think the
name of this essay we'll call it by
General Patton was the secret of victory
and he's got and this is this is where
you kind of start to realize that Patton
was a really smart and educated
individual because he's a very eloquent
writer especially for a guy that swore
so much but a very eloquent writer and
we'll go to this here despite the years
of fought and oceans of ink which had
been devoted to the elicitation of war
its secrets still remain shrouded in
mystery indeed it is due largely to the
very volume of available information
that the veil is so thick so everyone's
been trying to figure out war for a long
time and because so many people have
written about it that's what makes it
hard it's one of the things that makes
it hard to understand is that so much
stuff has been written about it and by
the way that whole opening opening
letter to George like we could have just
broken that entire thing down maybe we
should have but when he's talking about
you need to read history mm-hmm so he
goes on here war is an art and as such
is not susceptible of explanation by
fixed form you lie so where's this crazy
thing and it's you can't just say okay
this is what war is
no it's an art it's like trying to
explain art can you explain art can you
explain why someone likes this painting
but not that painting but but the other
person likes that painting but not this
painting you can't explain that you
can't explain why universally most
people like this painting universally
most people like this song right you
can't explain them otherwise guess what
people just go oh go I need to make a
hit song no I'll just produce one yeah
the formula yeah I'm real I know one can
can describe what makes a good video
because the echo Charles you're here now
this is something you are clear
hot to talk about okay a little bit more
than weapons loadout yeah probably so if
it was hey we just need to make a good
video and it'll go fire all right cool
hey hey echo go make a viral video do me
a favor just go make a viral video
you can't ya can't do you literally
can't do it yeah actually that's a good
comparison because they're so and
especially now and probably more in the
future where there's gonna be a lot of
information about a lot of people start
writing about it you know or write more
about it about what makes a viral video
that's like perfect end of the day yeah
it's a perfect thing because everybody
wants to make a viral yeah but I mean
everybody wants to make a viral video
but you can't just open up the formula
and say okay cool what we need to do is
it needs to be 38 seconds long and you
just have this type of soundtrack and
he's have this type of visuals and this
type of voiceover good ok produce it
boom do it
gangman style or whatever that was how
did it right how does that end up being
one of the most it might be the most
viewed video of all time right but it's
up there we held that I know for at
least three months of time my little
kids between the ages of whatever they
were six and eight we're walking around
the house singing Gangnam style yes sir
yeah and I'm saying haven't wait and
hold on let me play Black Sabbath for
you please yeah and even when people do
to make the formula yep like super
ambiguous and guess what that same guy
there okay well we made Gangnam style
just make another one
yeah no I don't even think there was
another one yeah yeah there was I mean
that's like a group right I think that's
like a music group see it's we don't
even know yeah yeah that's kind of know
a guy it's a one guy yeah but he's like
artists he's the artist or whatever I
don't think it's just some comedy dude
it's like no no it's not a comedy he was
a legit like pop guy yeah yeah and he
made that song but then he tried to make
another one mm-hmm and it wasn't you
know you just can't there's no forms no
formula
there's no same thing with war and here
we go back to the book away from Gangnam
style
we're going back to the book yet from
the earliest time there has been an
unending effort to subject its complex
and emotional structure to dissection to
enunciate rules for its waging to make
tangible its intangibility one might as
well strive to isolate the soul by the
dissection of the cadaver as to seek the
essence of war by the analysis of its
records that's a pretty powerful right
you might as well in order to find out
what makes war war you it's like looking
for the soul in a body yeah and then he
says yet despite the impossibility of
physically detecting the soul its
existence is proven by its tangible
reflection in acts and thoughts so we
know we exist mm-hmm it's there but you
can't open up the body and find it so
with war beyond its physical aspect of
armed hosts there hovers an impalpable
something which on occasion though
dominates the material as to induce
victory under circumstances quite
inexplicable so sometimes things happen
in war that victory is achieved and no
one can really even understand how it's
inexplicable yeah he goes on the great
warriors were too busy and often to in
apt to write contemporaneously of their
exploits saved in the form of
propagation propaganda reports while
what they later put on paper as
biographies were retrospect colored by
their vain strivings for enhanced fame
or political conditions then confronted
him so when these great warriors wrote
it was afterwards because they have time
to do while they're fighting so
afterwards and then they kind of got a
little ego involved which here's here's
got General Patton calling everyone out
on their ego they or there's some
political situation going on that's why
they wrote it a certain way so you don't
even get the truth from the Warriors
themselves because they don't have
I'm and or they do it afterwards in
which case it's colored or as it's a
miss colored by their ego or the
political environment that their it with
the efforts of historians the case is
even worse those who write at the time
are guilty of partisanship and the urge
of hero-worship so even someone that's
an historian right now they're they got
those problems in peace the scholar
flourishes in war the soldier dies so it
comes about that we view our soldiers
through the eyes of scholars and
attribute to them scholarly virtues so
since it's the scholarly people telling
it they paint these people to be you
know scholarly and that's not always the
case
seeking obvious reasons for the obscure
we analyzed their conduct as told by
historians and assign as reasons further
success apparent trivial things so he's
saying look we we look at someone in the
past who was a great warrior or a great
leader and we say okay they were a great
leader because of this or cuz of that
because that's what some scholarly
person wrote about trivial things music
has a myriad music has its myriad of
musicians but only its dozen masters so
with painting sculpture literature
medicine or trade or videos many are
called but few are chosen so that's what
he's saying is that well these leaders
are the same way like there's there's
there's people that make music but these
combat leaders there's not too many of
them that actually rate you know
Beethoven hmm or Tony Iommi nor can we
concur wholly with the alluring stories
in the advertising sections of our
magazine which port point to the Golden
Path of a success to all and sundry who
follow that particular phase of home
education that they happen to advocate
so just like the get-rich-quick scheme
is not going to work
these little thinking that these little
leadership things that you learn okay
they're not really gonna help you as
much knowledge is power but to a degree
only its possession per se will raise a
man to mediocrity but not to distinction
so you can be smart you can learn a lot
but that doesn't mean it couldn't get
you there in art and the funny thing as
you read this ERG there's a whole this
whole thing is like an egotistical
writing right cuz he's saying listen
there's normal people and then there's
there's you can have knowledge that'll
get you so far but to truly be the
master this is pretty rare and is he
implying that he is a little bit a
little bit in our opinion indeed the
instruction obtained from such courses
is of less moment to future success than
his ambition which prompted the study
that's interesting right and so if
you're a person that says hey I want to
be good leader I'm gonna reach out and
start trying to learn how to lead does
that ambition that's gonna make you a
good leader or I want to make a lot of
money so I'm gonna do this thing and
that's gonna make me a more money it's
the ambition is more important in making
you actually successful than the course
that you bought huh interesting
in considering these matters site should
not be lost of the fact that while there
is much similarity there is also a vast
difference between a successful soldier
and the successful man in other
professions success due to knowledge and
personality is the measure of ability in
each case but to all except the soldier
it has vital significance only to the
individual and to a limited number of
his family and associates so success is
important when you look at of any other
profession it's important to be
successful because they person can take
care of his associates and his family
right so that's very important to be
successful for your family and for your
associates and then he continues on
while the soldier while with the soldier
success or failure means infinitely more
as it must of necessity be measured not
in terms of personal honor or affluence
but in the life happiness and honor of
his men and his country way heavier
right and and let's face it you know
that's kind of we hold military people
in high regards even though I mean you
can find out you can go look you know
what the Admiral of the Navy makes the
Chief of Naval Operations makes you can
go look it up he's making whatever he's
making like a hundred and thirteen
thousand dollars a year you know I mean
then he's in charge of billions of
dollars worth of equipment whereas
somebody that's in charge of a
medium-sized company is making probably
10 or 15 or 20 or even a hundred times
I'd pay a hundred times more than what
this seat the Chief of Naval Operations
makes but we hold him in high regard why
because this guy isn't just protecting
or taking care of you know a company
he's taking care of his troops and he's
taking care of the country so that's why
being a military leader is held in high
esteem rightfully so you're not just
judging someone based on their amount of
money that they make continue on hence
the search for that elusive secret of
military success sole genius personality
call it what you will is a vital
interest to all of us beyond question
personal knowledge is a fine thing but
unfortunately it is too intimate
when for example we recall a railroad
that railroad accident the picture that
most vividly presents itself to us is
the severed blue grey hand of some child
victim not the misread signals which
precipitated the tragedy
so with war experiences the choking gas
that strangled us sticks in our memory
to the more or less complete exclusion
of the important fact that it was the
roads and the consequent abundant
mechanical transportation peculiar to
the Western Europe
which permitted the accumulation of
enough gas gels to do the strangling so
we get caught up looking at this one
small outcome of the problem but we
don't look at it from a strategic view
we don't see the big picture he says a
British writer has said the
characteristic of war and by the way I'm
not reading this whole thing I'm jumping
through parts of it so there might be it
might sound a little bit disjointed but
it's not as disjointed when you're
actually reading it he continues in
another little part here a British
writer has said the characteristic of
war is its constant change of
characteristic but as is ever the case
with amorphous with morphisms his remark
needs explanation the and here's his
explanation there is an incessant and
constant change of means to it to attain
the inevitable end but we must take care
not to let these inevitably sundry means
past or predicted attain undue eminence
in the perspective of our minds so what
is he saying there he's saying you've
got you've got these things that change
about how we're gonna achieve some goal
and those things you can get caught up
in those things they can attain undo
evidence so you can believe that they're
more important and then he says since
the beginning
there has been an unending cycle of them
and for each its advocates have claimed
adoption as the sole means of successful
war so all the time new war this is the
most important thing this is the most
important thing this is the most
important thing and then he says yet the
records of all time show that the
unchanging ends have been our and
probably ever shall be the securing of
predominant force of the right sort at
the right place at the right time that's
the most important thing you get the
strongest force at the right place at
the right time that's how you win all
these other things that we're talking
about that
they they're they're fake and again this
is according to Patton and we could
argue about those I'm telling you what
he's saying is that the most important
thing is to be have to have the
strongest force at
the right place at the right time mmm
it's hard argue with that yeah
continuing on in this scholarly
avocation soldiers of all important
nations use at the present time what
purports to be the best mode of
instruction the the applica tori method
the characteristics of some concrete
problem are first studied in the
abstract and then tested by applying
them with the assumed forces and
situations in in solving annales
problems either on the terrain or a map
representation of it so what he's saying
there is the normal mode of instruction
as you look at a map you look at where
you're gonna maneuver your forces and
then you figure out how you're going to
apply your forces and you play a little
game of chess on a map or on a terrain
model or even walking the terrain
actually physically doing it and then he
says this so that makes sense right we
understand that you're gonna look at
this do you know how are you gonna
maneuver your pieces this method not
only familiarizes the student with all
of the tools and technicalities of his
trade but also develops the aptitude for
reaching decisions and the
self-assurance derived from demonstrated
achievement okay cool so by doing that
by looking at a map by looking at
terrain by going out and walking through
the terrain by going out and simulating
combat you're gonna increase your what
does he say your self-assurance your
aptitude for reaching decisions that's
gonna happen it's gonna make you better
but then he says but at always as always
there is a fly in the ointment high
academic performance demands infinite
intimate knowledge of details and the
qualities requisite to such attainments
often inhabit bodies lacking personality
man that's a crazy thing to think about
right that you've got this people that
are willing to study and willing to work
but what they miss is they don't have
they they don't have the personality mmm
they don't have the charisma
so they're smart to book smart right
that's the term that gets used yeah and
this person yeah and that's the thing
that comes out as a negative right
someone says oh you know he's really
book smart they don't say that like all
these super book smart no that's who
he's talking about he's talking about
people that are book smart yeah and then
he says and also the striving for such
knowledge often engenders the fallacious
notion that capacity depends on the
power to acquire such details not the
ability to apply them so you got someone
over here that can memorize what's in
the book but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they can take what's in the
book and apply it you notice that in
jujitsu right you get someone that
understands the move yeah but you gotta
learn you gotta know how to well look
Jiu Jitsu is an interesting example cuz
you can take someone who teach them to
move and you're gonna get it and they
can achieve a good level but the people
that can go next level are the people
that can take those things and apply
them in different ways different
situations different scenarios and then
create things out of it that's the
difference between or not even but this
is I think someone can be just a good
applier and be a world champion in
jiu-jitsu like someone that studies and
is great and knows the moves they can be
a world champion but to be like the
elite of the elite
you got to have that next level you got
to be able to take those things and
apply create next level yeah and not the
sku thing towards making videos or
nothing like that that seems to be the
top well but you see the end with a lot
of stuff like where do you see this with
weapons as well you know like sometimes
and then okay so you run into this on
YouTube where it's like okay you can
look you can look up videos on how to
make videos right and go and then so
after a while you can kind of discern
okay this person just read the
directions you know you know how you get
that impression from somebody and it
doesn't matter
totally necessarily video it can be a
lot of stuff when it's like you just get
the impression that they read the
directions and they did it good they
didn't perfect but you can sort of tell
versus
a guy who's like maybe a little bit more
creative with it or yeah you can see you
can tell they understand the whole
comprehensive thing and then they can
add their own personal little element
well the example that I use which I've
used before is you can take a flier and
put it up in a guitar Center and say hey
I need someone that can play you can
pick the most complicated
songs ever and there's you'll get 20
people that will call you up and they'll
actually be able to play those songs and
yet they're all working regular jobs
because they didn't have that thing that
creative thing they learned the
mechanics of the job but they couldn't
they can't create something new yeah no
offense I mean I wish I could play
guitar like that I can't but that's what
separates that's why that's why there's
people that are incredible musicians
guitarists technicians
maybe musicians is it started as
musicians imply that they got that
creative spark - I don't know they mean
to me yeah I don't know yeah maybe okay
well yeah I guess on though I guess
you've got incredible technical
musicians that can play any song on
whatever instrument but they don't have
that little thing and that's what he's
talking about
they're book-smart yeah what about you
know you get these okay you know the
old-school art right that real valuable
art like yes Picasso and all this then
you have these master forgers where are
they on this whole vein question maybe
like a little of both I I mean I think
they're they're like the technical
guitarists that can lay down the riff
exactly you can't tell the difference
but it doesn't really matter because
they can't create something new right if
you're a master forger that's great but
you you're not gonna be remembered
because you didn't create anything so
creativity is what we're talking about
here which again you know when we went
over the Marine Corps manual tactics
with Dave Burke like think about how
often they talked about creativity good
yes good deal there think about how
often they talked about creativity yeah
and I've been talking about since day
one I think it was on the first time I
was on Tim Ferriss I said combat is an
exercise in creativity and it
is and that's what he's saying yeah for
the master forger essentially will
always have that limitation no matter
how good no matter unless he can break
out right and yeah and you know what I
thought you were going with this was
like the modern art you know where it's
just some random thing and and you can
look at and go well my four-year-old
could have created that right yes and
then there's other people going wait a
second you're missing something here
that this is why this is creative this
is why this is important whatever and
what's interesting also is when people
when you when you when you're that good
of an artist at drawing things you have
to get that good at drawing things
realistically before you can break out
and see them from a different
perspective I think a lot of present
sure yeah I don't know about that one I
mean not to say that that's not true but
it's one of those things like are you
saying earlier there is no for me lie
there even in an evaluation of art
really I mean we are all trained to
understand there's a well-known critic
of art but is there even such thing as a
critic of art officially yeah not really
no and it's it's it's weird too because
like with music there's music that is so
popular that I can't stand you know and
most of the music that I like is not
popular what does that mean means you're
special bro obviously I guess that art
is in the eye of the beholder
in many cases one might say okay yeah
because some people they don't and I and
maybe I misunderstood what you meant
when you said the artist has to be able
to draw like yeah like good first right
for the breakup but a lot of artists I
mean from what I understand they don't
necessarily know how to like draw that
good it's more of just their like the
idea behind the result kind of thing you
know I don't know I'm not sure I think
he was go first and they just go deep in
their head and they're like hey that you
know the invoke like everything in them
did point to because like with some of
the old like punk rock bands that really
like had a big impact it wasn't because
they were good musicians it's because
their emotion in
ocean leer aw right yeah he just people
heard and went whoa this is this is a
different thing and so that's you could
be you could be totally right that's the
same thing right you don't necessarily
have to be a fine artist before you
start drawing crazy stuff right or drugs
drawing abstract stuff let's say not
necessarily true yeah
even music like you know the guy super
impressive where these guys like they
may or may not even be a homeless guy
but they're on the street oh yeah I got
a bucket yeah and no like shop in the
bucket and they're like doing all this
stuff and it sounds really like dope but
it's like I don't know like is it
reaching everybody well then we're not
reaching anybody everybody I posted up
there was some guy there was like a
bunch of bumps I mean bumps in San Diego
I was out for dinner and they were
playing bluegrass you ever seen someone
with it's like a like a broom pole or
whatever a broom broom stick into like a
upside down wash bin with a string on it
and it's a bass okay well it's like what
you'd see in the olden days yeah and
then there's someone was plucking a
banjo and someone else was playing
guitar and these people were clearly
there were there were homeless people
you know and they were probably between
the ages of I would say maybe 20 to 20
to 26 so they're pretty young and and I
was walking and I just heard him and I
was thinking man this band sounds good
right and I get up and I see they're
just completely homeless and they were
jamming and I actually posted it on
Instagram and you know we got done and
my son I was with my son and my son was
like those guys weren't good and I said
yeah I know that was impressive and what
does that mean that means they are well
your question was are they reaching
everybody no they're not reaching
anybody they're reaching it literally
for people who are standing there
watching them right so what's better so
is
so okay I was having this debate this is
a long time with Tim Tim 14 so he was
like saying uh he he was making music or
whatever and he goes deep you know with
his music like what he's saying Zarek's
you will and something like whatever and
he and so we're talking about it like
what's better music right and he's like
oh like I think basically his premise
was underground rap is better than you
know popular rap now and and I had no
dog in the fight but I was just kind of
more just taunting him a little bit and
he was really emotionally dug in on this
one and then so I was like okay I was
like well how do you prove that you know
just cuz you like it better it doesn't
mean overall it's better you got to be
able to measure it so I'm like okay so
little wayne with the it was the song go
DJ you've heard that song DJ anyway it's
real popular song at the time and i
happen to like it and I was like no go
DJ is better than all your underground
rap I just said it to trigger him
nothing that's the fact or nothing but
but I used the measurement to I was like
okay how many albums have you know you
guys sold like or how are we gonna
measure it you know and we couldn't
really hit the network he couldn't
really hit the nail on the head as to
why it was better
why underground rap is better you know
but I sort of had some leg to stand on
because I had the measuring tool you
know but at the end of the day I think
which I didn't say in the argument
because you know it would have been kind
of a cop-out given what we're doing
there is no really way to tell that's
what I'm saying it's like it's all are
just cuz it reaches just cause a bunch
of people I don't love go DJ that's not
a life-changing song but if it's on like
we're gonna enjoy it then there's so
there's that side of the spectrum right
like no no maybe
what's your name Britney Spears
something like this you know some of us
think Brittany's pretty deep but
whatever saying it's on this side of the
spectrum yeah a lot of the time and then
on the other side it's like I don't know
something like super deep that not many
people know about about the people who
do know about it it's like man that's my
life song kind of thing you know so it's
a spectrum there but who's to say what's
better you know well yeah it's well I
think I'm to say
better of course where's the yeah so I
guess the whole point of this entire
divergence that we've just taken is that
just like in art and music there's a
spark that you have to have and it's the
same thing with leadership and so now he
continues on with this thing that the
people that they that the more that they
learn the more that they've learned from
the books that better they're gonna do
and he says this obsessed with this
thought students plunge deeper and even
deeper their exertions but in meshing
them more until like mired mastodons
they perish in a morass of knowledge
where they first browsed for sustenance
I guess iPads a good writer so you
picture these big giant mastodons that
you know fall into this murder this
giant pit of knowledge it's just too
much for him mhm mhm and they die that's
what happens this young leaders just
trying to read everything is coming from
a guy that tells you to read everything
I know when I say that I mean Patten's
telling you you need to read but what
he's saying is like you can go so far
into that you're you just end up well
perish in a morass of knowledge and he
continues on when the prying Spade of
the unbiased investigator has removed
the muck of official reports and the
mire of self laudatory biographies from
the swamp of the world war then the
skeletons of many such military mammoths
will be discovered and what I love about
this is as I as anyone knows from the
books that we cover on this podcast I've
said since a day one oh why don't you
cover this book about the Great War this
book about world war two or this this
book that was written by this great
historian I'm like oh no I like
first-person accounts I actually like
first-person accounts and Vaugh as often
as I can from like the frontline
soldiers of course I like the generals
too and the Colonel's that's great but I
like to hear what the frontlines have to
say and that's what that's part of what
I like about his idea that just reading
from this from this high altitude
doesn't necessarily give you the
information you need
he continues on beyond questions no
soldiers ever sought more Dylan
diligently own sorry he says amidst
their mighty remains will lurk the
elusive secret of German failure he's
talking about world war 1 beyond
question no soldiers ever sought more
diligently for pre-war perfection they
built and tested and adjusted their
mighty machine and became so engrossed
in its visible perfection in the
accuracy of its bearings and the
compression of its cylinders that they
neglected the battery when the moment
came their masterpiece proved
inefficient through lack of the define
divine athleticism an inspiration a
divine thing and that is the soul of a
leader so that the Germans were really
rigid and the way they prepared things
and again this is his viewpoint but it's
a pretty good viewpoint that the Germans
in World War one coming out of that
Prussian coming out of that that
Prussian mentality like this is the way
we're gonna do things but they forgot
that you gotta have a soul you gotta
have the soul of a leader and that's
what happened to him that's what he
means the battery like where's that
energy come from I guess what the soul
of the leader and he says this truly in
war men are nothing a man is everything
in acquiring erudition we must live on
not in our studies so in order to
acquire great knowledge you you have to
you have to live on the studies not in
them we must guard against becoming so
engrossed in a specific nature of the
roots and bark of the trees of knowledge
as to miss the meaning and grandeur of
the force that they compose that's a
really complicated way of saying don't
miss the forest through the trees he
fails the simplicity
mm-hmm as has been pointed out the
secret of victory lies not wholly in
knowledge it lurks invisible in that
vitalizing spark intangible yet as
evident as lightning the warrior soul
that's where he's saying the victory
lies the warrior soul we shall now seek
to evaluate and place in there just
ratio the three essentials to victory
inspiration knowledge and force which he
also calls mass we may therefore
postulate that no one element be its
sole knowledge or mass is dominant that
a combination of any two of these
factors gives a strong presumption of
success over an adversary relying on one
alone and that the three combined are
practically invincible against a
combination of the other two so here's
the important things inspiration
knowledge and and force or mass and he
actually I'd not cover him now but he
gives some examples of where these
things were important through history
I'm not gonna cover them right now but
these three things are what you need for
victory he says man cannot live by bread
alone and that as a man thinketh so he
is have been for generations droned from
countless pulpits as the texts for
prolix and unconvincing sermons until
cognizant of the phrases has been
somewhat dulled yet they contain an
infinity of truth and I think you say
this a lot it means like when something
that gets said all the time cliche yeah
there's a reason too cliche is a cliche
right there's a reason people say it
yeah because there's some what does he
call it there's some infinity of truth
in there right so that's what he's
saying so these things man cannot live
by bread alone and it has a man thinketh
so he is he those are cliches but
there's truth in them
war is conflict fighting is an elemental
exposition of the age-old effort to
survive it is the gold
glitter of the attackers eye not the
point of the questing bayonet that
breaks the line oh that's good I'm gonna
read that one again it is the cold as a
gold it is the cold glitter of the
attackers eye not the point of the
questioning bayonet that breaks the line
it is the fierce determination
determination of the driver to close
with the enemy not the mechanical
perfection of the tank that conquers the
trench it is the cataclysmic ecstasy of
conflict in the flyer not the perfection
of his machine gun which drops the enemy
in flaming ruin yet volumes are devoted
to armaments and only pages to
inspiration so this actual man the human
element is more important than the
bayonet than the tank and then the
aircraft and then the machine gun and
yet we talk about these are we to his
books written about these different
weapons of war but not enough written
about the soul of man continuing on
since by necessity limitations of map
problems he's going back to this this
whole idea of figuring out things on a
map and we're doing a terrain walk since
by a necessity limitations of map
problems inhibit the student from
considering the effects of hunger
emotion personality fatigue leadership
and many other imponderable yet vital
factors he first neglects and then
forgets them crazy right you you look at
this map when you figure we renew for
your people and you think what you've
read about but you forget about the
thing that I try and talk about all the
time which is human nature which is
understanding people understanding
people understanding hunger emotion a
personality fatigue leadership and all
these imponderable things those are what
you need to be concerned about as a
leader going on obsessed with admiration
for the intelligence which history is
ascribed to leaders past he forgets the
inseparable connection between plans the
flower of the intellect and execution
the fruit of the soul he's getting an
a-plus in an English class right now
isn't it the inseparable connection
between plans which are the flower of
the intellect and execution the fruit of
the soul you gotta have both you gotta
have both yes you gotta have plans but
then you gotta be able to execute
continuing on since the historian
through lack of experience and
consequent appreciation of the
inspirational qualities of generals
fails to stress them he does emphasise
their mental gifts which since he shares
he values this guy was smart like me
this guy was educated like me that's
what made him so great just like me yeah
sometimes people will say that even if
they aren't necessarily that you know
well like me and you're alike in this
way and then they'll say some cool
quality that you have you know just sort
of implying yeah I'm like that yeah I'm
like that too and that's what this is
right
oh the historian says oh this guy was
very educated like I am yeah and like
you said there's no always necessarily
but he was wealth Rick sure and that's
what they stress doesn't it's doesn't
stress the inspirational qualities of
the general doesn't stress that because
he focuses on the fact that the guy was
educated or the guy who went to Oxford
or the guy went to whatever West Point
mm-hmm is that because it's it's more
concrete it's definitely more concrete
but it's also it's a shared value it's
like what you just said yeah you know
this guy was smart like when somebody
does something when when another seal
does something cool and I'm like yeah we
know using the day just like me dude
then it continues on hugging the notion
of intelligence he pictures armies of
incident pawns moving with the precision
of machines and the rapidity of lights
guided in their intricate and resistless
evolutions over the battlefield by the
cold effulgence of his emotionless
celebrations as transmitted to them by
wire and radio through the inspiring
medium of coded messages oh that's just
a get some right that's what they
picture though then you know this
happens today this happens today with
them I just was just responding to
someone on social media that was
implying this exact thing that oh well
you know jakku you were on you you only
been in charge of teams of seals and so
guess what they are though those are
incident pawns moving with the precision
of machines and the rapidity of light
like no bro actually but that's what
people think they're wrong continuing
doubtlessly he further assumes the same
superhuman intelligence will translate
those sombre sentences into words of
fire which shall electrify his chest men
into frenzied heroes who heedless of
danger shall dauntlessly translate this
stillborn infants of his brain into
heroic deeds so if you think you can
just put out the word and now everyone's
gonna go execute it with with undeniable
tenacity and vigor you're wrong
continuing on shrewd critics have
assigned to all manner of things oh
sorry shrewd critics have assigned
success to all manner of things and here
are some of the things that they
assigned success to tactics shape of
frontiers happily placed rivers
mountains or woods intellectual ability
or to the use of artillery all in a
measure true but none vital so yeah you
can be successful from all these
different
and and the shrewd critics say oh you
were successful because this er you were
successful because of that you were
successful because of your tactics or
your frontier or the river or the woods
or whatever and it continues nor is it
even the speed of the operations that
the secret lays but in the inspiring
spirit with which they so inoculated
their soldiers as to lift weary footsore
men out of themselves and to make them
march forgetful of agony that's the
difference
according to Patton mm-hmm in
considering war we must avoid that
adoration of the material as exemplified
by scientists who deny who deny the
existence of aught they cannot cut away
so the scientists look at it go well if
you can't see it doesn't exist
you can't weigh it it doesn't exist so
therefore we're not gonna give any
credit to these things that we can't
exactly wrap our hand around the magic
spark mm-hmm as a mirror shows us not
ourselves but our reflection so it is
with the soul and with leadership we
know them but by acts they inspire or by
the results they have achieved so you
don't see them you only know them by the
acts that they make happen or things
that are achieved through them
continuing on like baguettes like in the
armies of the great we seek the
reflection of themselves and we find
self-confidence enthusiasm abnegation of
self loyalty and courage so this is this
is big right and this is this this I
won't get into it but here's what you
find self-confidence right boom that's
what you find self-confidence enthusiasm
abnegation of self what is that right
abnegation of self is denial of the self
this is like this is I'm not the most
important thing loyalty and courage
resolution no matter how adamant
made it to knowledge no matter how
infinite never begat such a progeny so
being firm in your resolution and
knowing a lot no matter how much of
those two you have you never get as much
as you get with self-confidence
enthusiasm abnegation of self loyalty
and courage such offspring only arises
from bloodlines as elemental as
themselves the leader must be incarnate
of them now this is what we really like
that's a pretty bold statement right
mm-hmm
hey Here I am a leader in the army my
name is general pat my name is well he's
probably like a captain or maybe a major
at this point when he's writing this and
he's saying that in order to be a really
good leader you have to be bloodline
incarnate in you but then he says this
which is awesome this is where I get a
little you know I he's starting to move
a little bit out of the box here that he
comes right back in the box I had to
paraphrase this one a little bit but nor
is the suggestion that birth is the only
means of producing such a leader
there are certainly born leaders but the
soldier may still overcome his natal
defects by unremitting effort and
practice imagine that mm-hmm
what's that the old nature versus that's
that's what it is I've got a book called
leadership strategy and tactics there's
a there's a chapter and they're called
born or made mm-hmm and the answer is
both and that's the same thing that
General Patton saying here you you look
you can be born a great leader but you
can still overcome your natal defects
just my unremitting effort and practice
that's how you can get good self
confidence of the right so I think this
is where he's gonna start hammering yeah
so he starts hammering through this list
of things so the first one is self
confidence self confidence of the right
sort as differentiated from bump Jewess
presumption based in ignorance is the
result of proven ability
the sense of conscious achievements its
existence presupposes enthusiasm for
without this quality no one would endure
the travail of acquiring self-confidence
so self-confidence takes time in order
to get self-confidence you have to be
enthusiastic and you have in order
because you have to be successful and
thinks it's self-confidence you can't
just wake up and have it you have you
it's it's conscious achievement it's
proven ability and the more you prove
able the more confidence you gonna get
which is interesting that in my new book
I talk about how do you get someone to
increase their confidence you give them
tasks that they can achieve that's
exactly what he's saying over time
that's how you build up self-confidence
he continues on here the enthusiasm
which permits the toil and promises the
achievement is simply an all absorbing
preoccupation in the profession elected
so when you're fired up for something
when you're enthusiastic that's what
allows you to overcome the toil and the
times that you drop the balls that
you're learning how to juggle
you just keep picking them up mmm
Anderton is the next one endurance to is
linked with self-confidence mentally it
is the ability to subvert the means to
an end to hitch a wagon to a star and to
attain it physically it presupposes
sufficient enthusiasm to force on nature
no matter how reluctant the obligation
of constant bodily fitness through
exercise hmm then he says the expanding
waistline means the contracting heart
line both in length and vigor and then
he says witness Napoleon at and after
Jenna the Battle of Jena which is where
the Prussians figured out that they need
to use maneuver warfare and
decentralized commander but because
that's because they got crossed by
Napoleon and I didn't
I don't Lee Napoleon that Jenna was in
good shape and if probably an after
Jenner he maybe he let it go so constant
bodily fitness through exercise mental
ability to hitch a wagon to a star and
attain it right
that's endurance next up abnegation of
self seems perhaps incongruous when
applied to such selfish persons as
frederick or napoleon but this is not
the case so this is kind of funny too
because right do be bad to do mmm whose
baton - right
I mean Patton has at least a big of a
Nico as Napoleon or or Frederic but this
is not the case he says self can be
subordinated to self the Corsican
leading his grenadiers zat lodi
subordinated the life of bonaparte to
the glory of napoleon so once again even
patton you know this is a former
humility right that's what it is it's
like everyone else is more important
than me that's what it is next one is
loyalty loyalty is frequently only
considered as faithfulness from the
bottom up it has another an equally
important application that is from the
top down one of the most frequently
noted characteristics of the great who
remain great is the unforgiveness and of
loyalty to their subordinates it is this
characteristic which binds with hoops of
iron their juniors to them a man who is
truly an unselfishly loyal to his
superiors is of necessity
so to his juniors and they to him so
this is great right
loyalty up and down the chain of command
you're just not loyal to the people
above you you're loyal to the people
below you you take care of them and if
you take care of them they're gonna take
care of you once again it's in the book
leadership strategy and tactics next
courage moral and physical is almost a
synonym of all forgoing traits it
fosters the resolution to combat and
cherishes the ability to assume response
ability the ability to assume
responsibility be it forced successes or
failures we call that extreme ownership
he says but as with biblical candle
these traits and now he's that was the
last trait now he's talking about - all
these traits these traits are of no
military value if concealed a man of
diffident manner will never inspire
confidence
a cold reserve cannot beget enthusiasm
and so with the others there must be an
outward visible sign of the inward and
spiritual grace it then appears that the
leader must be an actor and such is the
fact but with him as with his B wig to
compare he is unconvinced convincing
unless he lives the part
so yes the leader has to be an actor but
guess what if the leader doesn't
actually believe what he's doing if
everyone's gonna see through it just
like an actor a B weekd
actor B twig that's like a person
wearing a wig okay so cuz I thought we
said an actor meaning someone who takes
action but no straight straight upper
stage a person on the stage the person
on the stage has to act and he's
unconvincing unless he lives the part
and that's way leaders gotta be you
gotta live it you gotta think it you've
got to believe it stay in character and
if you don't believe it then no
everyone's gonna see through it yeah
yeah that's kind of true with everybody
huh you know people like you back in the
day when I was a personal trainer and
you get a personal trainer who's like
kind of out of shape you know okay but
they you know according to them they
know everything kind of thing is like
Brian's kind of I mean we can see it on
you obviously but yeah if you feel that
you know so yeah you're not gonna follow
them here's your's way more apt to
follow you know some of someone's a
fitness instructor someone that's in
good shape yes but more more importantly
for me
is if you don't really believe in what
you're saying as a leader yeah everyone
can see it and where this really comes
into play and this is such an incredible
thing and I've talked about it
over and over again and I I put it
there's an edition of dichotomy
leadership that I talked about this I
think was the Barnes & Noble Edition
they put like a section in there that I
had written this article about and I
talked about it in leadership strategy
and tactics and that's this if if your
goal is to take care of yourself
everyone can see it yeah and you're
gonna fail that's the way it is like if
your goal if you're if you're willing to
step on people and crush them in order
to move up the chain of command
everyone's gonna see it and you're gonna
fail now look you might get a couple
wins here and there I get it but long
term you're gonna fail if your goal is
to take care of your team and accomplish
the mission that's what your true goal
is number one you're gonna be successful
in taking care of the team and
successful in accomplishing the mission
and then guess what a byproduct is you
will be successful as well but the
minute you say well wait a second maybe
I'll just focus on myself for a second
it's the wrong move it's the wrong move
what you want to do is say how can I
best take care of my people definitely
you want to say that's what you want to
believe that's what you want to do and
if you do that you take care of your
people and you take care of your mission
and that's where the way you're
operating everyone can see it up and
down the chain of command by the way
mm-hmm and eventually that will play out
correctly if you're looking to take care
of you people will see that up and down
the chain of command and eventually that
will play out incorrectly and then he
says can a man acquire and demonstrate
these characteristics that's these
characteristics self confidence
endurance abnegation of self loyalty and
courage can a man then acquire and
demonstrate these characteristics the
answer is they have they
and for as a man thinketh so is he so
all these things if you think this way
you can become that way and he finishes
this out by saying this the fixed
determination to acquire the warrior
soul and have acquired it to either
conquer or perish with honor is the
secret to victory George S Patton jr.
major March 26 1926 so this guy's got a
lot of a lot of things to talk about I
rolled into a third session next time
delivering knowledge and I think it's
just so important to think about these
things especially a guy that's
controversial like Patton you know
there's there's a there's another quote
about Patton you know because they
called hatton old blood and guts and
there's there's a quote about Patton
that someone else said it was our blood
his guts you know so there's some
diagram that's that's a rough statement
right that's a rough statement so
there's controversy you know around
Patton there's controversy about some of
the things that he did you know there's
the whole episode of him slapping around
some of the guys that had left the
frontlines for various reasons that were
not ham physically wounded so some of
the guys had some truck mental trauma
you know whether they were shell-shocked
mmm-hmm and what's interesting about
this is this is a distant one I'm sure
we can get into but I'm reading another
book written by uh by a leader in world
war two and he's I was just reading this
section where these guys are coming to
him crying
we need yo you I can't take it anymore
and one guy does it and he's like you
know talks to him and you know says to
get back on the line the next guy comes
and he oh he's crying he's distraught
he's like I need to get off on I can't
take it anymore and the guy says you
know uh Smith just came to me with these
problems he did a much better job acting
than you're doing so my point and the
guy eventually broke down and just said
yeah but I mean I just it's really hard
me he says look I know it's hard
everyone's having a hard time you can do
this my point is when you had there was
people that were shirking their duty
there were people that would look
everyone was scared Patton says it a
thousand times everyone was scared
whether someone actually had you know
shell-shocked who knows certainly when
you talk about caring about your people
and you get somebody in a bad situation
I mean dick winters talked about this
when these guys were freaking out on the
frontlines how he would handle it
certainly wasn't by slapping him around
but that all I'm saying is that there's
controversy around Patton and yet he's
got great you take that controversy as
part of what you can learn at least I do
and definitely a ton of perspective that
he has so we'll we'll look it we'll keep
looking at Patton I believe maybe not
next episode but who knows you never
know what that next episode is gonna
bring I do know this I did some live
gigs around America sure they're there
over now when this podcast comes out the
last two were Seattle and San Francisco
which both sold out which was awesome so
to everyone that went to the jockle live
shows around the country
thank you and for everyone that's asked
for more looks like I'm gonna do some
more so Jaco live we'll put that out
soon on when these next ones will happen
Andy and the other thing is the
leadership strategy tactics and Field
Manual that I talked about today
a couple times and just just want to say
thanks to everybody it's it's been crazy
that the sales have been great and I
know that's all because you all are out
there getting after it spreading the
word made it number one in a bunch of
bunch of different a bunch of different
outlets that actually measure this stuff
so believe me that every time I I think
about that I think about everyone that
that listens to this podcast and that
spread the word and you know bought
yourself a first edition and by the way
there was some controversy someone sent
a picture on social media and that cover
was different and said you know I waited
as too long and I got the second a dish
and I said no you're in Europe or you're
in England I think England New Zealand
Europe and and basically outside America
there's a different cover it's still
first a dish as of right now cool why is
there a different cover you know what I
guess they have different styles or
something that hey this is they they
just said hey this is the this is not
the way books look over here mmm and you
know I just said is it Roger that I'm
not from New Zealand I'm not from
Australia I'm not from England I'm not
from Germany
I'm from America and if you're telling
me that this is like in the book it's
not that much different but it's
different but apparently that's normal
you know and yeah make sense I mean I
don't you know I I try and keep my ego
in check right yeah I'm not George S
Patton saying it I'm right and history
will prove it I'm not thinking that when
somebody tells me something that's a
professional in another arena I go okay
I'll get maybe explain it to me you know
and actually I did say that to them and
they sent me a bunch of other books and
said hey here's like this is what books
like look like over here your book will
not look like a book even yeah maybe I'm
wrong you know I could've been wrong I
could have said you know what let's hold
the line and maybe people would be
looking at it going oh yeah this I'm
getting this book I don't know
yeah well I mean it kind of makes sense
if you consider the concept right you
know how like you know some cars here
like if they're super exotic they'll
have the steering wheel on the side of
the road or the other side of the car
it'll be on the right side yeah you know
I wouldn't call that super exotic that's
just a car that was built in the foreign
country right but so yeah okay period
okay so let's say you're shopping for a
car and then you see like the steering
wheel on those really hey I'm not really
used to that yeah you know and you could
say organ amelie or whatever but you
know if you it's pretty quick together
or for whatever mental reason doesn't
matter it's like Azzam that needs to be
crossed yeah tighten that up a little
bit yeah but if you go to Australia
right that's everybody assumed same so
it's like boom we're used to that here
we're used to this here on many
different levels you know something's
bigger than the other okay the car thing
that's probably on this side of the
spectrum but unless book covers movie
posters or movies poster if it doesn't
look like movie poster like how is that
even gonna land as a movie poster same
saying yeah
so that's what we did so I guess the
point is if you got the other cover
you're still good I'll still be I'll
still give you some knuckles on the
first dish when I open it up now I might
might open it up and it might say third
a day that's different in which case you
know let me just look I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna embarrass you in
front of everybody but I'm gonna look at
you you're gonna know I'm gonna know
yeah that you didn't get the first dish
there's still first edition available
right now but so anyways I want to say
thanks to everyone for all that yeah I'm
super stoked and I appreciate appreciate
it
now speaking of acquiring a warrior soul
which I know it's a little bit of a bold
statement it is but we know from Patton
that we can move in the right direction
as far as improving our categories that
we want improvement it can move us
towards
being a little bit stronger a little bit
better a little bit faster a little bit
more of a warrior yeah anything you can
recommend that could help us with that
to be able to tactical advice for us
maybe either conquer or perish with
honor mmm
yeah we can take to Jitsu good and
really that's really what it is what did
you do is I mean I don't want to say
really that's what it is but we'll just
say that's a part of it to conquer or
perish with honor if me and you were
about to roll mm-hmm
and I when we go to shake hands because
it's a part of the deal it's not a rule
but it's cusp ECTS the honorable thing
respect what if instead of shaking my
hand I surprise you with like a
guillotine or something like that
I conquered but not with honor well when
I escaped the guillotine sure okay all
right then you are gonna pay right then
I'm the one who's gonna perish and by
the way if you well I know this is
happening but it happened to me like
where somebody's all excited like all
amped up and they think if their big day
sure and so you go to shake their hand
and like they either a don't and by the
way we're not talking like a formal
handshake as if we just signed a NATO
peace treaty we know we're just talking
a little bump and roll right now
slap little little little slap bump and
roll that's all we're talking about yes
but occasionally especially especially
this happens if you're going with
someone that like is really trying to
kill you and then you submit them and
then they're gonna go again but they're
so engrossed in like okay I'm gonna make
you get you this time
they're like forget their like their
minds insane yes yeah yeah that's uh
that's good dad's or you can go one step
further we haven't ever done that by the
way I don't think I've ever got so amped
up that I'd like just lost my mind I
think you have I've done it jokingly
with no I think you've done it where
you've gotten to the point where you
you're you want to go again so bad that
you've that like I'll put my hand up and
you'll like get reminded and be like oh
yeah we're actually like friends I could
be wrong and overall you wrong but you
put put this way
general we're because as frustrated as
I've ever gotten with you which is like
pretty frustrating yeah like deep deep
engulfing frustration there was always
like a little Governor on there where
it's like even like my expressions of
frustration like there's always a hint
of like joke okay or like genuine I
don't think I've ever that's not even
how I get for it that's not how I look
when I get for real in life frustrated
like all get more quiet than anything
but with you it's like and we said
talked about this before where you're so
like you can take kind of anything you
know like if I cheat with you like I
straight up like you're rolling with
Andy and I jump on your back and I put a
real choke in make you tap or what I
feel like you can like take that you
know yeah like you won't be all mad at
me not externally anyway but you know I
feel like you can just look externally
that would be retribution retribution
but you see no saint won't damage the
relationship in any way you know like I
feel like like you can kind of take
these kinds of things so it's almost
like I'm in like a little country or you
know me believing that it's a good thing
I feel caught in what I'm saying is I
feel comfortable to just be like yeah
you know fu or whatever I find sneak
attacks on the jujitsu mat somewhat
offensive yeah yeah I've had a couple
people do it over the years like you
know like tap someone out and like hey
we were over by the wall and like kind
of just turn my back to start going back
towards the center and have someone jump
on my back and then put a joke in yeah
that's that's cool but I'm first of all
like I'm gonna get out and then I'm get
you're gonna pay because that's just you
know that's you know what it is yeah and
I think what offends me about it is the
like you can tell that their ego has
flared up and they're trying to recover
that or whatever yeah and so that maybe
it is my ego that starts to flare up and
I fit but I I feel more like it's it's a
scenario where someone's out wide right
there needs
there needs to be a lesson that gets
taught right at that point yeah I think
you're right and I agree where if
somebody actually also asked me this on
social media really recently which was
like hey going with the guy he's
grinding his knuckles into my neck the
whole time like into my face and he's
like so I got on top and just like
mounted and and like punished him with
neon stomach or something like that
mm-hmm
is that is that bad you know there's a
little JIT about question and I was like
now it's proofed like if someone if
someone wants to get all freaking
hostile and kind of I don't wanna use
the word dirty because it's not really
dirty but it's what would you call that
would you call that what they call it in
Portuguese it's like gross right it's
means I'm like kind of brutal yeah like
if someone's getting crazy with me like
that yeah then I'll probably put some
kind of uh some kind of a slightly
increased measure back on them right
just slightly increase knock I'm not
it's not like I'm going to oh now I'm
gonna break someone's arm right not at
all but if you wanna you know grab hold
my whatever and start squeezing it's
like okay cool yeah you're gonna it's
weird cuz the balance not emotional by
the way yeah okay cool you yeah I see
where you're at right it's not not cool
and here's how you can know yeah it can
be tricky though because some people is
there's different levels of that like
some people literally don't know what
they're going yeah man listen just relax
bro you know sometimes like hey I
probably should've said that to this guy
to like just being like hey man if you
get crazy with people they might get
crazy with you what you want to do is
try and learn and try and have a good
time this is an actual combat we're just
having fun we're trying to learn yeah
you should you should really go with
that approach you know that's smart
that's a smile yeah because yeah like I
don't know yeah they don't know
and then then there's like this
intermediary level where they know but
it's not aimed at you specifically it's
aimed at sort of everyone you know you
know the kind of you know the kind of
become maybe come from an environment
where it's like that or you know so it's
like their whole attitude towards any
competition is like crush you kill you
like you're my enemy kind of thing and
they just have this kind of subconscious
attitude about it so that's how they
roll
and then then you get on the other side
inspector in which I think is the ideal
candidate for the repercussions is the
kind guy where he's like mad at you
maybe not even necessarily because it's
you but just he's having a bad day or
he's just like frustrated because he's
not winning or whatever kind of thing
and then it's kind of he's turning it up
a notch like and how you say he's
stepping out of line and that's what it
is it's like you're you're stepping
slightly outside of like the mutual like
respectful agreement of this friendly
like training slash company yeah and the
other thing is you gotta remember is
like when I roll with Andy mm-hmm like
man we're smashing each other I mean
it's full he's you know we're we'll do
whatever like it's full we might as well
be competing for you know the World
Championships yes because if there's a
chance where he's trying to choke me and
I've got my chin down he'll he'll choke
my face no no doubt about it
I'll do the same to have like it yeah
but if I was rolling with someone I
didn't really train with all the time
and they buried their chin a bag okay
I'll go for an arm lock or whatever you
know they're not just correct you're not
just putting your forearm across there
across their mandible and cranking it as
hard as you can to open up a neck
exposure or just get him to tap from
that right yeah you know so yeah and
that's that's a subtle kind of dancey I
do too with you like who you roll with
or whatever but I think generally
speaking there's like an understanding
where I think we all sort of understand
where yeah like that if you're real
close to someone and you already know
you guys are used to that competition
you can take it a little bit further
yeah yeah for sure
and then even on top of that we're like
and this I guess goes for people who
you're at least have a good rapport with
whether you're else with them or not
we're okay so there's you know Isaiah
right you the he's okay so we'll roll or
whatever and sometimes it'll go into in
this ongoing scramble right so like one
time he was like it was an ongoing
scramble I don't know if he was on
purpose going outside of the mat like
outside of the door he kind of did like
to escape but he went outside of the mat
and I just chased him outside and jumped
on is about we're out in the not on the
mat anymore over by the water fountain
you know but I chased him not because no
no this it it's still on it was like
halfway joking you know getting like ooh
we're still fighting but it was like
joking no sometimes people do that like
serious yeah you know like you're
heating the mop in this corner and
there's no children so so here's here's
the important part of this whole thing
if the the the reason that this is
important is because if you and I are in
a real fight and you crank my face that
doesn't mean anything
yeah I can I'm just gonna I'm not like
what am I gonna do I'm gonna try and
bite you right there's if you're
cranking my face I'm not gonna tap to it
yeah so it is not a legit thing unless
it opens up a choke right if you can
make the pain open up choke with and
that's fine I guess what I'm saying is
there's things that you could do to
somebody like here's another one
breaking someone's finger right like I
could grab through your fingers if we
were in a real fight grab two your
fingers grab one of your fingers and
just break it does that end the fight no
no no it doesn't end the fight and in
fact it has a not a huge impact on the
fight immediately right you know like
it's not gonna end the fight immediately
so therefore for me to grab it your
fingers and try and break one of your
fingers is not good training partner
yeah because it doesn't really impact
the in the the fight look it has a small
impact of the fight but but like i
couching right and if this is a good one
because I've had people try and gouge
out my eyes before it's it doesn't
change the outcome of the fight at that
moment look if you get your finger deep
enough because I I have not done this
but I've had friends that have dug in
for eyes and it can it's definitely it
makes people react right but if
someone's a trained fighter it's not
this game changer it's not as a game
changer as a choke is yeah so there for
me going hey you can just attack my eyes
and we're good that no because if you do
that guess what rap scratches on my eyes
yeah and yet it doesn't mean that you
could ever beat me it just means that I
have scratches on my eyes doesn't change
the outcome so I guess there's the
there's this strange part about this
we're not the strange part that's it's
important because we do train hard and
we train hard for a reason yeah that's
one of the best things about jujitsu is
you can go ninety nine percent you can
go a hundred percent and hey if I get
you an unlock you tap if you give me an
armlock I tap cool then we go again if I
doubt your eye it we can't go again and
realistically it's hard to gouge out
someone an eye and it didn't really
change the outcome a fight because
you'll still be fighting with one eye
yeah so anyways yeah and even if you're
training for actually fighting or
whatever like in outside of MMA I guess
but here's a good one biting off
someone's ear yeah right you know Igor
yeah that's that's what made me think of
it so so Igor you know he got into a
street fight yeah and you know you hear
all these people say oh you rip off
someone's ear they're gonna be done
guess what somebody bit off Igor's ear
and he could--he like I remember has
like bro and I said well what happened
he goes oh my god I got side control and
then you know mount and finished him you
know with his ear off yeah big giant
chunk of his ear gone yeah and I mean
visibly gone forever yeah you know Mike
Tyson's done yeah Mike bigger than mike
tyson so this idea that all just bite
this guy's here it's like that's why if
you and i were to go to train today and
I'm like you know what just to make it
more realistic I'm gonna bite your ear
off and then you're like bro what are
you doing it stopped does that mean I
went no it means we lost in training
yeah and I got a false sense of security
thinking that just biting off your ear
would stop you when the reality is would
it happen to Igor he just was like oh
cool now you're really now you're right
so I know there's some guy that was on
the receiving end of that that's
probably listening right now going on I
wish I wouldn't have been that guy's ear
cuz no man heavily paid the price of
knowing cuz this is the thing to bring
us back to jiu-jitsu
the the jiu-jitsu that you train every
single day is effective it's very
effective
you don't need to bite you don't need to
pull hair you don't need to gouge eyes
sure you can add that stuff it's fine in
a real situation it's fine but the
fundamentals that you know are
infinitely more powerful than these
little additional things that you might
think in your brain or a game-changer
yeah they're not yes so jiu-jitsu so we
want to Train it let's go with that
premise we want to change it so do you
have any recommendations on what we
should utilize to train jiu-jitsu yes
discipline but attire wise we're gonna
go G nogi boom so uniform for a geek is
a geek uniform for no G is not a geek
it's a rash guard anyway best G's in the
world factually are from origin so go to
origin main Dom you don't even have to
ask anymore what gear should get get an
origin key and take your pick
I don't care whatever color you like
I'll put that yeah and and not only can
you get keys there and someone actually
just asked this they saw a picture of
Pete and the deco sure standing with
origin jeans on and said but they they
said where do you get those gay pants
with pockets
you just know their origin jeans which
are also available at origin main comm
made in America from the very very
thread that they are created with was
made in America American denim yes oh
yeah good that's actually only the only
jeans I wear yes some designer jeans too
by the way
mmmn I realize this until you know I
revisited them it's been so long
on the last yes or jamayne cons freaking
it all this stuff also they got shirts
and doggers and sweat suits would you
call them sweat suits mmm I guess so you
know other clothing attire elements yeah
so yeah jeans like jockle said also
supplement yeah and you mentioned
discipline I figure are about discipline
that we sell discipline the supplement
the screen mission some traditions our
own discipline
powder which you can get chocolate over
which is very tasty you can also get the
discipline canned which is awesome and
Mulk and by the way if you didn't know
this yet the vitamin shop yeah the
vitamin shop in America which I think
there's 700 stores all over the place
they now have the whole line of jaco
fuel so if you want to go and get some
you can go and get some good something
vitamins shellfish or you can go to
origin Maine dot-com and get some there
yep so yes multi additional protein and
the form of dessert discipline for your
brain and body at the same time mm-hmm
discipline go the pill and the can-can
is like the energy drink a delivery
system yeah call it we don't like to say
energy drink because energy drinks
generally speaking are not healthy that
the stigma will not miss it it's an
earned astigmatism they got a bunch of
nasty chemicals yes but this one does
not does not but if you take away the
nasty chemicals all the sugar and that
far as it can caffeine excessive cat 300
400 milligrams of caffeine you do not
need that in one can yes so take away
all those negative things you we have
everything else is is essentially energy
drink material so it's I think it's just
a stigma okay
it has a lightning bolt come the logo in
one of the little oh yeah that's true
that's not because it's an energy drink
is because it's tropic thunder yeah and
then it's in one of those little slim
cans so cuz lemon-lime doesn't have a it
has a it has a little little lemon lime
on it on the citric site citrus cycles
it just wedge in there in the logo okay
okay yeah yeah so yeah exception little
little twist there if you will unless if
you like energy drinks but you're like
hey I'm not down for all that that mmm
negative noise boom right here that's
the deal
every system also speaking of vitamin
shoppe you me Dakota Meyer JP Danelle
will be in the san diego vitamin shop on
February 8th to kick it with the troops
what did what is that February 8th yeah
all right there you go boom also what
else we got ok can't yes are also
warrior kid monk yeah no additional
protein for the young ones for the youth
yeah if you will best thing in the world
for the children agree
strawberry chalk and don't forget about
chocolate white tea yes sir
if you want to deadlift 8000 pounds get
it yep it's true happens to be certified
organic as well also yes Jocko has a
store and what we have a store happens
to be called Jacko's store simplicity so
go jackal store calm sorry this is where
you can get your shirts and hoodies and
beanies and hats both flex fit and
snapback trucker hats while representing
on the path you know discipline equals
freedom good stand by to get some back
to the book back to the book all that
stuff unless you go there Jacque look
like I said chuckle store calm if you'd
like something get something represent
while you're on this ever lasting path
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already on your iTunes or
stitcher or Google Play Spotify you know
all these parts where we live your
podcast subscribe yep and and also we
have the grounded podcast which we
almost just recorded one when we went on
this big tangent just a minute ago but
grounded podcast we talk about all
things life jiu-jitsu and you can check
that one out lost of the warrior kid
podcast for kids and don't forget about
the warrior kid soap made by Aden and
the new soap is out you see the logo yes
it's all it's called killer soap you
know it's got ingredients in it that
help deter Mike microbials microbes and
funguses kind of to get rid of that
stuff so if you're a person that does
something called jiu-jitsu you probably
want some of this yes and you know
what's really cool about it it's black
the soap is but the soap is black
because it's got charcoal here good
thing yeah by the way so so there you go
get yourself some killer soap my young
kid he started a business no big deal
started it when he was like 11 started
his own business got goats and decided
what can I make with goat milk oh I know
what I can make soap killer soap which
allows everyone in the world to stay
clean also YouTube we have a YouTube
channel official where Eko Charles is
constantly trying his utmost to make a
viral video
the ingredients
he's got the formula Kenny - can he pull
it off I think my hypothesis that'll
never be categorized beyond a hypothesis
and Inc I don't think you can make a
viral video like like that probably you
can't know if you're sure you like okay
I'm gonna formulate there is no formula
for them interesting to find out if
anyone's ever said okay I'm gonna make a
viral video and then it worked I would
think you know what no there's some
people like on YouTube like YouTube
stars or whatever that they can make
consistent viral videos well yes sir yes
sir but yeah I think it depends on what
you mean my viral video cuz technically
what I understand of our video is like
it just comes kind of from this resource
and then it goes viral so so if the
platform is already too big yeah I got
10 million subscribers and it gets 11
million views is that a viral video okay
point taken but the question is has a
viral video ever been manufactured
proactively
with intention yeah I'm sure somebody's
muscle yeah I'm sure someone had a
really good idea and just came it hit
him and they're like you know what
and they discord it was more of a hope
thing it wasn't a guaranteed thing but
it was just like hey man this I don't
see how this couldn't go viral kind of
thing and they just happen to be right
you know yeah but I don't know that
there's a formula that someone can
follow the rest in the event of us us
making a viral video this is worse thing
that would be me over you yeah making
viral videos nobody you're the talent
though so what they call it officially
you're the talent person in front of
they can't believe it were rough shape
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm gonna do my best
and so subscribe to that channel you can
watch EKKO Charles and I talk about
skinny knees or what have you I think
that's the most I think that's the best
the funniest video might not be the best
but it's it's it's pretty funny I watch
it once every two months and I still
laugh everyone yeah there's someone else
to be agree with that
psychological warfare if you need a
little help getting over a moment of
weakness you're not alone you know I
will be there with you press play on
your mp3 media device and I will enter
your ear and give you words of
discipline focus and will so go to
psychological warfare where the artists
mm-hmm is Jocko willing mmm it's any mp3
platform we also have a visual
representation which you can find on
flipside canvas com run by my brother
Dakota Meyer where you can he's making
let's just call it graphic
representations of the path so hit that
up I got a bunch of books leadership
strategy and tactics field then you
won't thank you all spread the word
write a review on Amazon
and then get way the warrior kid the
whole series 1 2 & 3 marks mission where
there's a will and where the warrior kid
Mikey the Dragons before the little kid
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
for the older kid that needs to be on
the path the audio version of that is on
mp3 platforms as well and then of course
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership that is the books I wrote
with my brother Leif babban laying out
the principles of leadership that will
help you in business in life and if you
need more help than that we have a salon
front which our leadership consultancy
where we solve problems through
leadership and go to echelon front comm
for that EF online
that's excellent front online leadership
training because leadership is not an
inoculation
we got the muster coming up in 2019
where are we gonna be we're gonna be in
Orlando we're gonna be in Dallas and
we're gonna be in Phoenix Arizona go to
extreme ownership calm every one of
these that we have done has sold out
these are gonna sell out too so if you
want to come and you wanna bring your
team go there now extreme ownership calm
and we have EF overwatch an EF Legion
for almost since the inception of
echelon front people have been asking us
hey where can I hire veterans that know
and understand the principles you talk
about that demand signal grew to a point
where we now have an answer to that
demand signal if you are at a company
and you want to hire people that
understand extreme ownership and
understand the dichotomy of leadership
and understand the leadership strategies
and tactics that we talk about all the
time they go to EF overwatch or EF
Legion to find people that will come and
help lead your company to victory and if
you're a veteran and you're looking for
your next mission this is where you find
it you find it @ EF overwatch you find
it @ EF Legion go check them out and if
for some completely unknown reason you
still feel
need to communicate with us after all
these hours then we are available on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on
Jah Rasta Ecco is that echo Charles and
I am at Janko willing and thank you to
everyone out there for your support we
couldn't do this podcast without you
being in the game without you getting
some deaf core or some origin gear or
some choco supplements all of which
those things they support the podcast so
we appreciate all you troopers out there
trooping and thanks to those of you that
are out there in uniform the soldiers
sailors airmen Marines the coast
guardmen who protect our way of life
every day and to our police and law
enforcement to the firefighters to the
paramedics and EMTs that dispatchers the
correctional officers that Border Patrol
Secret Service and all the other first
responders that protect us here at home
thank you for that and to everyone
remember what patent remember a patent
on us not only about war and leadership
but about life and that is the fact that
we all have weaknesses we all have
shortfalls no one was born perfect but
we can still overcome we can overcome
our natal defects through unremitting
effort and practice and as he told his
own son you can be born with a soul
capable of correct military reactions or
the body capable of having big muscles
but both qualities must be developed by
hard work so
don't sit back and accept the hand that
you've been dealt negative instead
overcome your weaknesses capitalize on
your strengths by getting out there and
getting after it and until next time
this is echo and Jocko out